un día antes de la retirada definitiva
de las fuerzas extranjeras las
evacuaciones de los refugiados afganos
se dan por terminadas sin embargo
cuántos son los que se quedaron atrás en
un afganistán de futuro incierto
podrían ser objetivos prioritarios para
los talibanes que ya los buscan porque
ayudaron a extranjeros y eso es una
línea roja para los talibanes con la
ayuda de una red clandestina vamos a
encontrarnos con algunos ex
colaboradores del ejército francés en un
lugar secreto de la capital todos estos
hombres en un momento u otro sirvieron a
francia durante su intervención en
afganistán
recibí este email en el que está escrito
que debo estar preparado para irme con
mi familia rápidamente que la embajada
me iba a llamar y que debo preparar mi
equipaje en seguidamente y todo lo que
teníamos ahora no tenemos nada
fuimos al aeropuerto pero no logramos
cruzar las puertas antes de ir hice
todos los papeles y los envié siguiendo
el procedimiento indicado por el
ministerio de defensa y de asuntos
pero la embajada dice que tenemos que
esperar
no podemos salir de nuestra patria
porque los talibanes registran todos los
teléfonos y miran todos los detalles la
situación es muy mala nuestra vida está
en peligro y hemos trabajado para el
ejército francés al servicio del pueblo
francés en afganistán ahora pedimos que
todos seamos evacuados del país request
su parte un tweet post pedimos al
ejército francés que se acuerde de que
un día fuimos nosotros quienes ayudamos
a sus soldados quienes les acompañamos
en sus misiones ahora son ellos quienes
deben ayudarnos no podemos ir a ninguna
parte
estos hombres y sus familias todavía
están aturdidos un día quizás su
sentimiento cambiará pero por ahora
sienten que francia los ha traicionado